The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today we're going
to introduce graph search
in general and talk about
one algorithm, which
is breadth-first search, and
understand how in principle you
can solve a puzzle
like the Rubik's Cube.
So before I get to
Rubik's Cubes let
me remind you of some
basic stuff about graphs.
Or I can tell you to start
out with, graph search is
about exploring a graph.
And there's many different
notions of exploring a graph.
Maybe I give you some
node in a graph, s,
and some other
node in a graph, t,
and I'd like to
find a path that's
going to represent a
problem like I give you
a particular state of a
Rubik's Cube and I want to know
is there some path that
gets me into a solved state?
Do I really want to
solve this on stage?
What the hell?
We started.
So this is a particularly
easy state to solve,
which is why I set up this way.
All right, so there you go.
Seven by seven by seven Rubik's
Cube solved in 10 seconds.
Amazing.
New world record.
So you're given some initial
state of the Rubik's Cube.
You're given the
targets that you
know what solved looks like.
You want to find this path.
Maybe you want to
find all paths from s.
Maybe you just want to
explore all the nodes
in a graph you can reach from s.
Maybe you want to explore all
the nodes in a graph or maybe
all the edges in a graph.
These are all
exploration problems.
They're all going to
be solved by algorithms
from this class and next class.
So before we go
further though, I
should remind you
what a graph is
and sort of basic
features of graphs
that we're going to be using.
This is also 6042 material so
you should know it very well.
If you don't,
there's an appendix
in the textbook about it.
We have a set of vertices.
We have a set of edges.
Edges are either
unordered pairs--
some sets of two items--
or ordered pairs.
In this case, we call
the graph undirected.
the graph directed.
Usually, there's only one type.
Either all the
edges are directed
or all the edges are undirected.
There is a study of
graphs that have both,
but we are not doing that here.
Some simple examples.
Here is a graph.
This is an undirected graph.
This is a directed graph.
The set of vertices
here is a, b, c, d.
here is a, b, c.
The set of edges here is--
E is going to be things
like a, b; b, c; c, d--
I think you get the idea.
Just for completeness,
V is a, b, c, d.
Just so you remember
notations and so on.
One of the issues we're going
to talk about in this class
is how do you represent a graph
like this for an algorithm?
So it's all fine to say,
oh, this is a set of things.
This is a set of things.
An obvious representation
is, you have
a list or an array of vertices.
You have an array of edges.
Each edge knows
its two end points.
That would be a horrible
representation for a graph
because if you're, I
don't know, at vertex, a,
and you want to know, well
what are the neighbors of a?
b and c.
You'd have to go through
the entire edge list
to figure out the
neighbors of a.
So it's been linear time just
to know where you can go from a.
So we're not going to
use that representation.
We're going to use some
better representations.
Something called
an adjacency list.
Over here, you've got things
like a, c; b, c; and c, b.
So you can have edges
in both directions.
What am I missing?
b, a.
So that's E, in that case.
There are a whole lot of
applications of graph search.
I'll make you a little list
to talk about few of them.
So we've got web crawling.
You're Google.
You want to find all
the pages on the web.
Most people don't just tell
you, hey, I've got a new page,
please index it.
You have to just keep
following links--
in the early days of the
web, this was a big deal--
following links finding
everything that's out there.
It's a little bit of an issue
because if you define it wrong,
the internet is infinite
because of all those dynamically
generated pages.
But to deal with
that, Google goes
sort of breadth-first
for the most part.
It's prioritized You want
to see all the things you
can reach from pages you
already have and keep going.
At some point, you give up
when you run out of time.
Social networking.
You're on Facebook.
You use Friend Finder.
It tries to find the friends
that are nearest to you.
Or friends of friends is
sort of a level to search.
That's essentially a
graph search problem.
You want to know what's
two levels or three
levels of separation from you.
And then you loop over those
and look for other signs
that you might be good friends.
You are on a network like the
internet or some intranet.
You want to broadcast a message.
So here's you.
You want to send data out.
That's essentially a
graph exploration problem.
That message, that packet, is
going to explore the graph.
Garbage collection.
I hope you all know that
modern languages have
garbage collection.
This is why you don't have to
worry about freeing things.
Even in Python--
even in CPython,
I learned-- there is a garbage
collector as of version two.
But also in PyPy, and
JPython and in Java--
pretty much every
fairly modern language
you have garbage collection.
Meaning, if there's some data
that's unreachable from--
So you have your variables.
Variables that can be
accessed by the program.
Everything that's reachable
from there you have to keep.
But if some data structure
becomes no longer reachable,
you can throw it away
and regain memory.
So that's happening behind
the scenes all the time,
and the way it's
being done is with
their breadth-first
search, which
is what we're going
to talk about today.
Another one.
Model checking.
Model checking is-- you have
some finite model of either
a piece of code, or a
circuit, or chip, whatever,
and you want to prove
that it actually
does what you think it does.
And so you've drawn a graph.
The graph is all
the possible states
that your circuit or your
computer program could reach,
or that it could possibly have.
You start in some
initial state, and you
want to know among all the
states that you can reach,
does it have some property.
And so you need to visit
all the vertices that
are reachable from
a particular place.
And usually people do that
using breadth-first search.
I use breadth-first
search a lot,
myself, to check
mathematical conjectures.
So if you're a mathematician,
and you think something
is true.
Like maybe-- It's hard to
give an example of that.
But you can imagine some graph
of all the possible inputs
to that theorem, and
you need to check them
for every possible input--
If this is true-- the
typical way to do that
is breadth-first searching
through that entire graph
of states.
Usually, we're testing
finite, special cases
of a general conjecture, but
if we find a counter-example,
we're done.
Don't have to work
on it anymore.
If we don't find a
counter-example, usually then
we have to do the mathematics.
It doesn't solve everything,
but it's helpful.
And then, the fun
thing we're going
to talk about a
little bit today,
is if you want to solve
something like a two
by two by two Rubik's
Cube optimally,
you can do that using
breadth-first search.
And you're going to do
that on your problem set.
To do it solving this one
optimally using breadth-first
search would probably--
would definitely-- take
more than the lifetime
of the universe.
So don't try seven
by seven by seven.
Leave that to the
cubing experts, I guess.
I think no one will ever solve
a seven by seven by seven
Rubik's Cube optimally.
There are ways to find a
solution just not the best one.
So let me tell you just
for fun, as an example.
This Pocket Cube, which is a
two by two by two Rubik's Cube.
What we have in mind is
called the configuration graph
or sometimes
configuration space.
But it's a graph, so
we'll call it a graph.
This graph has a vertex for
each possible state of the cube.
So this is a state.
This is a state.
Now I'm hopelessly lost.
Anyone want to work on this?
Bored?
No one?
Alright, I'll leave
it unsolved then.
So all those are vertices.
There's actually
a lot of vertices.
There are 264 million
vertices or so.
If you want.
To the side here.
Number of vertices is something
like 8 factorial times 3
to the 8.
And one way to see that
is to draw a two by two
by two Rubik's Cube.
So these are what you
might call cubelets,
or cubies I think is the
standard term in Rubik's Cube
land.
There's eight of them
in a two by two by two.
Two cubed.
You can essentially permute
those cubies within the cube
however you like.
That's 8 factorial.
And then each of them has
three possible twists.
It could be like this.
Or it could be like this.
So you've got three for each.
And this is actually
an accurate count.
You're not over-counting the
number of configurations.
All of those are, at least
in principle, conceivable.
If you take apart the
cube, you can reassemble it
in each of those states.
And that number is
about 264 million.
Which is not so
bad for computers.
You could search that.
Life is a little bit easier.
You get to divide by
24 because there's
24 symmetries of the cube.
Eight times three.
You can divide by three,
also, because only a third
of the configuration space
is actually reachable.
If you're not allowed
to take the parts apart,
if you have to get
there by a motion,
you can only get to 1/3
of the two by two by two.
So it's a little bit
smaller than that,
if you're actually doing a
breadth-first search, which
is what you're going to be
doing on your problem set.
But in any case, it's feasible.
That was vertices.
We should talk about edges.
For every move--
every move takes you
from one configuration
to another.
You could traverse it in one
direction and make that move.
You could also undo that move.
Because every move is
undoable in a Rubik's Cube,
this graph is undirected.
Or you can think of it as every
edge works in both directions.
So this is a move.
It's called a quarter twist.
This is a controversy
if you will.
Some people allow a whole
half twist as a single move.
Whether you define that as a
single move or a double move
is not that big a deal.
It just changes
some of the answers.
But you're still exploring
essentially the same graph.
So that's the graph
and you'd like
to know some
properties about it.
So let me draw a
picture of the graph.
I'm not going to draw
all 264 million vertices.
But in particular,
there's the solved state--
we kind of care
about that one, where
all the colors are aligned--
then there's all of
the configurations
you could reach by one move.
So these are the possible
moves from the solved state.
And then from those
configurations,
there's more places you can go.
Maybe there's multiple ways
to get to the same node.
But these would be
all the configurations
you can reach in two moves.
And so on.
And at some point,
you run out of graph.
So there might be a
few nodes out here.
The way I'm drawing
this, this is everything
you can reach in one move, in
two movies, in three moves.
At the end, this
would be 11 moves,
if you allow half twists.
And as puzzlers,
we're particularly
interested in this
number, which you
would call, as a graph theorist,
the diameter of the graph.
Puzzlers call it God's number.
If you were God or some omni--
something being.
You have the optimal algorithm
for solving the Rubik's Cube.
How many moves do you
need If you always
follow the best path?
And the answer is, in
the worst case, 11.
So we're interested in the worst
case of the best algorithm.
For two by two by
two, the answer is 11.
For three by three by
three, the answer is 20.
That was just proved
last summer with a couple
years of computer time.
For four by four by four--
I don't have one here--
I think we'll never
know the answer.
For five by five by five,
we'll never know the answer.
For six, for seven, same deal.
But for two by two by
two, you can compute it.
You will compute it
on your problem set.
And it's kind of nice
to know because it
says whatever configuration I'm
in, I can solve it in 11 moves.
But the best known
way to compute it,
is basically to construct
this graph one layer at a time
until you're done.
And then you know
what the diameter is.
The trouble is, in between
here this grows exponentially.
At some point, it
decreases a little bit.
But getting over
that exponential hump
is really hard.
And for three by three by
three, they used a lot of tricks
to speed up the
algorithm, but in the end
it's essentially a
breadth-first search.
What's a breadth-first search?
This going layer by layer.
So we're going to
formalize that in a moment.
But that is the problem.
So just for fun,
any guesses what
the right answer is for an
n by n by n Rubik's cube?
What's the diameter?
Not an exact answer,
because I think we'll never
know the exact answer.
But if I want theta
something, what
do you think the something is?
How many people here have
solved the Rubik's Cube?
Ever?
So you know what we're
talking about here.
Most people have worked on it.
To think about an n by
n by n Rubik's Cube,
each side has area n squared.
So total surface
area is 6 n squared.
So there's, roughly, stata n
squared little cubies here.
So what do you think the right
[INAUDIBLE] is for n by n by n?
No guesses?
AUDIENCE: n cubed?
PROFESSOR: n cubed?
Reasonable guess.
But wrong.
It's an upper bounds.
Why n cubed?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're
guessing based on the numbers.
Yeah.
The numbers are
misleading, unfortunately.
It's the law of small
numbers I guess.
It doesn't really look right.
I know the answer.
I know the answer
because we just
wrote a paper with the answer.
This is a new result.
From this summer.
But I'm curious.
To me the obvious answer is
n squared because there's
about n squared cubies.
And it's not so hard to show
in a constant number moves
you can solve a constant
number of cubies.
If you think about the
general algorithms,
like if you've ever
looked up professor's cube
and how to solve it,
you're doing like 10 moves,
and then maybe you
swap two cubies
which you can use to
solve a couple of cubies
in a constant number of moves.
So n squared would be
the standard answer
if you're following
standard algorithms.
But it turns out, you can
do a little bit better.
And the right answer is n
squared divided by log n.
I think it's cool.
Hopefully, you guys
can appreciate that.
Not a lot of people can
appreciate n squared divided
by log n, but here in
algorithms, we're all about n
squared over log n.
If you're interested, the
paper's on my website.
I think its called, Algorithms
For Solving Rubik's Cubes.
There's a constant there.
Current constant is not so good.
Let's say it's in the millions.
[LAUGHTER]
You've got to start somewhere.
The next open problem
will be to improve
that constant to
something reasonable that
maybe is close to 20.
But we're far from that.
Let's talk about
graph representation.
Before we can talk
about exporting a graph,
we need to know what
we're given as input.
And there's basically one
standard representation
and a bunch of variations of it.
And they're called
adjacency lists.
So the idea with
an adjacency list,
is you have an array
called Adj, for adjacency
of size V. Each
element in the array
is a pointer to a linked list.
And the idea is that this
array is indexed by a vertex.
So we're imagining
a world where we
can index arrays by vertices.
So maybe, you just
label your vertices
zero through v minus 1.
Then that's a regular array.
Or, if you want
to get fancy, you
can think of a vertex as an
arbitrary hashable thing,
and Adj is actually
a hash table.
And that's how you
probably do it in Python.
Maybe your vertices are
objects, and this is just
hashing based on the
address of the object.
But we're not going
to worry about that.
We're just going
to write Adj of u.
Assume that somehow you
can get to the linked list
corresponding to that vertex.
And the idea is,
for every vertex
we just store its
neighbors, namely
the vertices you can
reach by one step from u.
So I'm going to define that
a little more formally.
Adj of u is going to be
the set of all vertices,
V, such that u, v is an edge.
So if I have a vertex
like b, Adj of b
is going to be both a
and c because in one step
there are outgoing edges
from b to a and b to c.
So Adj of b is a, c.
In that graph.
I should have labeled the
vertices something different.
Adj of a is going to be
just c because you can't
get with one step from a to b.
The edge is in the
wrong direction.
And Adj of c is b.
I think that definition's
pretty clear.
For undirected graphs,
you just put braces here.
Which means you store--
I mean, it's the same thing.
Here Adj of c is going
to be a, b, and d, as you
can get in one step from c to
a, from c to b, from c to d.
For pretty much every--
At least for graph
exploration problems,
this is the
representation you want.
Because you're at some
vertex, and you want to know,
where can I go next.
And Adj of that vertex tells you
exactly where you can go next.
So this is what you want.
There's a lot of different
ways to actually implement
adjacency lists.
I've talked about two of them.
You could have the vertices
labeled zero to v minus 1,
and then this is,
literally, an array.
And you have--
I guess I should draw.
In this picture,
Adj is an array.
So you've got a, b, and c.
Each one of them is a
pointer to a linked list.
This one's actually going
to be a, c, and we're done.
Sorry, that was b.
Who said it had to be
alphabetical order?
A is a pointer to c,
c is a pointer to b.
That's explicitly how
you might represent it.
This might be a hash
table instead of an array,
if you have weirder vertices.
You can also do it in a more
object-oriented fashion.
For every vertex, v, you can
make the vertices objects,
and v dot neighbors
could store what
we're defining over
there to be Adj
of v. This would be the more
object-oriented way to do it
I've thought a lot about
this, and I like this,
and usually when I implement
graphs this is what I do.
But it is actually convenient
to have this representation.
There's a reason the textbook
uses this representation.
Because, if you've already
got some vertices lying around
and you want to have multiple
graphs on those vertices,
this lets you do that.
You can define multiple Adj
arrays, one for graph one, one
for graph two, one
for graph three
but they can all talk
about the same vertices.
Whereas here, vertex can
only belong to one graph.
It can only have one
neighbor structure
that says what happens.
If you're only dealing
with one graph,
this is probably cleaner.
But with multiple graphs, which
will happen even in this class,
adjacency lists are
kind of the way to go.
You can also do
implicitly-represented graphs.
Which would be to say,
Adj of u is a function.
Or v dot neighbors is a
method of the vertex class.
Meaning, it's not just
stored there explicitly.
Whenever you need it,
you call this function
and it computes what you want.
This is useful because
it uses less space.
You could say this uses
zero space or maybe v space.
One for each vertex.
It depends.
Maybe you don't even need
to explicitly represent
all the vertices.
You start with some vertex,
and given a vertex, somehow
you know how to compute, let's
say in constant time or linear
time or something, the
neighbors of that vertex.
And then from
there, you can keep
searching, keep
computing neighbors,
until you find what you want.
Maybe you don't have to
build the whole graph,
you just need to build enough of
it until you find your answer.
Whatever answer
you're searching for.
Can you think of a situation
where that might be the case?
Where implicit representation
would be a good idea?
Yes.
Rubik's Cubes.
They're really good.
I never want to
build this space.
It has a bajillion states.
A bajillion vertices.
It would take forever.
There's more
configurations of this cube
than there are particles
in the known universe.
I just computed that in my head.
[LAUGHTER]
I have done this
computation recently,
and for five by five by five
it's like 10 to the 40 states.
Or 10 to the 40, 10 to the 60.
There's about 10 to the
80 particles in the known
universe.
10 to the 83 or something.
So this is probably
10 to the 200 or so.
It's a lot.
You never want to build that.
But, it's very easy to
represent this state.
Just store where
all the cubies are.
And it's very easy to see what
are all the configurations you
can reach in one move.
Just try this move, try
this move, try this move.
Put it back and
try the next move.
And so on.
For an m by n by
n cube in order n
time, you can list all
the order n next states.
You can list all the
order n neighbors.
And so you can keep exploring,
searching for your state.
Now you don't want to explore
too far for that cube,
but at least you're
not hosed just
from the problem of
representing the graph.
So even for two by
two by two, it's
useful to do this
mostly to save space.
You're not really saving time.
But you'd like to not have to
store all 264 million states
because it's going to be several
gigabytes and it's annoying.
Speaking of space-- ignoring
the implicit representation--
how much space does this
representation require?
V plus E. This Is going
to be the bread and butter
of our graph algorithms.
Most of the things we're going
to talk about achieve V plus E
time.
This is essentially optimal.
It's linear in the
size of your graph.
You've got V vertices, E edges.
Technically, in
case you're curious,
this is really the size
of V plus the size of E.
But in the textbook, and
I guess in the world,
we just omit those sizes of
whenever they're in a theta
notation or Big O notation.
So number vertices
plus number of edges.
that sort of the
bare minimum you
need if you want an explicit
representation of the graph.
And we achieve
that because we've
got we've got v space just to
store the vertices in an array.
And then if you add up--
Each of these is an edge.
You have to be a little careful.
In undirected graphs, each
of these is a half edge.
So there's actually two
times e nodes over here.
But it's theta E.
So theta V plus E
is the amount of space we need.
And ideally, all our algorithms
will run in this much time.
Because that's what you need
just to look at the graph.
So let's do an actual algorithm,
which is breadth-first search.
So to the simplest algorithm
you can think of in graphs.
I've already outlined
it several times.
You start at some node.
You look at all the nodes
you can get to from there.
Keep going until you're done.
So this is going to explore
all of the vertices that
are reachable from a node.
The challenge-- The
one annoying thing
about breadth-first search
and why this is not trivial
is that there can
be some edges that
go sort of backwards, like
that, to some previous layer.
Actually, that's
not true, is it?
This can't happen.
You see why?
Because if that edge
existed, then from this node
you'd be able to get here.
So in an undirected
graph, that can't happen.
In a directed graph,
you could conceivably
have a back edge like that.
You'd have to realize, oh,
that's a vertex I've already
seen, I don't want to put
it here, even though it's
something I can
reach from this node,
because I've already been there.
We've got to worry
about things like that.
That's, I guess, the main
thing to worry about.
So our goal is to
visit all the nodes--
the vertices-- reachable
from given node, s.
We want to achieve
V plus E time.
And the idea is to look
at the nodes that are
reachable first in zero moves.
Zero moves.
That's s.
Then in one move.
Well that's everything you
can reach from s in one step.
That's adjacency of s.
And then two moves,
and three moves, and so
on until we run out of graph.
But we need to be careful
to avoid duplicates.
We want to avoid
revisiting vertices
for a couple of reasons.
One is if we didn't, we
would spend infinite time.
Because we'd just go
there and come back,
and go there and come back.
As long as there's
at least one cycle,
you're going to keep
going around the cycle
forever and ever if you don't
try to avoid duplicates.
So let me write down some
code for this algorithm.
It's pretty straightforward.
So straightforward, we
can be completely explicit
and write pseudocode.
There's a few different ways
to implement this algorithm.
I'll show you my favorite.
The textbook has a
different favorite.
I'm going to write in
pure Python, I believe.
Almost done.
I think I got that right.
So this is at the end
of the while-loop.
And at that point
we should be done.
We can do an actual
example, maybe.
I'm going to do it on
an undirected graph,
but this algorithm works just as
well on directed and undirected
graphs.
There's an undirected graph.
We're given some
start vertex, s,
and we're given
the graph by being
given the adjacency lists.
So you could iterate over
the vertices of that thing.
Given a vertex, you
can list all the edges
you can reach in one step.
And then the top
of the algorithm's
just some initialization.
The basic structure--
We have this thing called the
frontier, which is what we just
reached on the previous level.
I think that's going to
be level i minus one.
Just don't want to
make an index error.
These are going to be all the
things you can reach using
exactly i minus one moves.
And then next is going
to be all the things
you can reach in i moves.
So to get started,
what we know is s.
s is what you can
reach in zero moves.
So we set the level
of s to be zero.
That's the first
line of the code.
There's this other
thing called the parent.
We'll worry about that later.
It's optional.
It gives us some
other fun structure.
We set i to be one because
we just finished level zero.
Frontier of what you can reach
in level zero is just s itself.
So we're going to
put that on the list.
That is level zero. i equals
one So one minus one is zero.
All good.
And then we're going to iterate.
And this is going
to be looking at--
The end of the iteration
is to increment i.
So you could also
call this a for-loop
except we don't know
when it's going to end.
So it's easier to
think of i incrementing
each step not knowing
when we're going to stop.
We're going to stop whenever
we run out of nodes.
So whenever frontier
is a non-empty list.
the bulk of the work
here is computing
what the next level is.
That's called next.
It's going to be level i.
We do some computation.
Eventually we have
what's on the next level.
Then we set frontier next.
Because that's our new level.
We increment i, and then
invariant of frontier being
level i minus 1 is preserved.
Right after here.
And then we just keep going
till we run out of nodes.
How do we compute next?
Well, we look at every
node in the frontier,
and we look at all the nodes
you can reach from those nodes.
So every node, u, in the
frontier and then we look at--
So this means there
is an edge from u
to v through the picture.
We look at all the edges
from all the frontier nodes
where you can go.
And then the key thing is
we check for duplicates.
We see, have we seen
this node before?
If we have, we would have set
it's level to be something.
If we haven't seen
it, it will not
be in the level hash table
or the level dictionary.
And so if it's not in
there, we'll put it in there
and add it to the next layer.
So that's how you
avoid duplicates.
You set its level to make sure
you will never visit it again,
you add it to the next frontier,
you iterate, you're done.
This is one version
of what you might
call a breadth-first search.
And it achieves
this goal, visiting
all the nodes reachable
from s, in linear time.
Let's see how it works
on a real example.
So first frontier is this thing.
Frontier just has the node
s, so we just look at s,
and we look at all
the edges from s.
We get a and x.
So those get added
to the next frontier.
Maybe before I go too
far, let me switch colors.
Multimedia here.
So here's level one.
All of these guys, we're going
to set their level to one.
They can be reached in one step.
That's pretty clear.
So now frontier is a and x.
That's what next becomes.
Then frontier becomes next.
And so we look at
all the edges from a.
That's going to be s and z.
s, we've already looked at,
it already has a level set,
so we ignore that.
So we look at z.
Z does not have a
level indicated here,
so we're going to set
it to i which happens
to be two at this point.
And we look at x.
It has neighbors s, d, and c.
We look at s again.
We say, oh, we've already
seen that yet again.
So we're worried about
this taking a lot of time
because we look at s
three times in total.
Then we look at d.
d hasn't been set, so we set
it to two. c hasn't been set,
so we set it to two.
So the frontier at
level two is that.
Then we look at all
the neighbors of z.
There's a. a's already been set.
Look at all the neighbors of d.
There's x.
There's c.
Those have been set.
There's f.
This one gets added.
Then we look at c.
There's x.
That's been done. d's been done.
f's been done.
v has not been done.
So this becomes a
frontier at level three.
Then we look at level three.
There's f.
D's been done, c's been
done, b's been done.
We look at v. c's been
done. f's been done.
Nothing to add to next.
Next becomes empty.
Frontier becomes empty.
The while-loop finishes.
TA DA!
We've computed-- we've
visited all the vertices.
Question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
What notation?
PROFESSOR: This is
Python notation.
You may have heard of Python.
This is a dictionary
which has one key value,
s, and has one value, zero.
So you could--
That's shorthand in Python for--
Usually you have a
comma separated list.
The colon is specifying
key value pairs.
I didn't talk about parent.
We can do that for a little bit.
So parent we're initializing to
say, the parent of s is nobody,
and then whenever we
visit a new vertex,
v, we set its parent to be
the vertex that we came from.
So we had this vertex,
v. We had an edge
to v from some vertex, u.
We set the parent of v to be u.
So let me add in
what that becomes.
I'll change colors yet again.
Although it gets hard to
see any color but red.
So we have s.
When we visited a, then the
parent of a would become s.
When we visited z, the
parent of z would be a.
Parent of x is going to be s.
Parent of d is going to be x.
The parent of c
is going to be x.
The parent of f--
it could have been either
way, but the way I did it,
d went first, and so
that became its parent.
And I think for v,
c was its parent.
So that's what the parent
pointers will look like.
They always follow edges.
They actually follow
edges backwards.
If this was a directed
graph, the graph
might be directed that way
but the parent pointers
go back along the edges.
So it's a way to return.
It's a way to return to s.
If you follow these pointers,
all roads lead to s.
Because we started at s,
that's the property we have.
In fact, these pointers
always form a tree,
and the root of the tree is s.
In fact, these pointers form
what are called shortest paths.
Let me write down a
little bit about this.
Shortest path properties.
If you take a node, and
you take its parent,
and you take the
parent of the parent,
and so on, eventually
you get to s.
And if you read it
backwards, that will actually
be a path in the graph.
And it will be a shortest
path, in the graph,
from s to v.
Meaning, if you look
at all paths in the graph
that go from s to v--
So say we're going from
s to v, how about that,
we compute this path out of BFS.
Which is, follow a
parent of v is c, parent
of c is x, parent of x is s.
Read it backwards.
That gives us a
path from s to v.
The claim is, that
is the shortest
way to get from s to v. It
might not be the only one.
Like if you're going from s
to f, there's two short paths.
There's this one
of length three.
of length three..
Uses three edges.
Same length.
And in the parent
pointers, we can only
afford to encode
one of those paths
because in general there might
be exponentially many ways
to get from one node to another.
We find a shortest path, not
necessarily the only one.
And the length of that path--
So shortest here means that
you use the fewest edges.
And the length will
be level of v. That's
what we're keeping track of.
If the level's zero, you can
get there with zero steps.
If the level's one, you
get there with one steps.
Because we're visiting
everything you can possibly
get in k steps, the
level is telling you what
that shortest path distance is.
And the parent
pointers are actually
giving you the shortest path.
That's the cool thing about BFS.
Yeah, BFS explores the vertices.
Sometimes, that's
all you care about.
But in some sense,
what really matters,
is it finds the shortest way to
get from anywhere to anywhere.
For a Rubik's Cube,
that's nice because you
run BFS from the start
state of the Rubik's Cube.
Then you say, oh,
I'm in this state.
You look up this state.
You look at its level.
It says, oh, you can
get there in nine steps.
That's, I think, the average.
So I'm guessing.
I don't know how to
do this in nine steps.
Great, so now you
know how to solve it.
You just look at
the parent pointer.
The parent pointer gives
you another configuration.
You say, oh, what move was that?
And then you do that move.
I'm not going to solve it.
Then you look at the
parent pointer of that.
You do that move.
You look at the parent
pointer of that.
You do that move.
Eventually, you'll get
to the solved state,
and you will do it using
the fewest possible moves.
So if you can afford to put the
whole graph in memory, which
you can't for a big Rubik's Cube
but you can for a small one,
then this will give you a
strategy, the optimal strategy,
God's algorithm if you will,
for every configuration.
It solves all of them.
Which is great.
What is the running
time of this algorithm?
I claim it's order V plus E.
But it looked a little wasteful
because it was checking
vertices over and over and over.
But if you think
about it carefully,
you're only looking--
what's the right
way to say this--
you only check every edge once.
Or in undirected graphs,
you check them twice,
once from each side.
A vertex enters the
frontier only once.
Because once it's in the
frontier, it gets a level set.
And once it has a level set,
it'll never go in again.
It'll never get added to next.
So s gets added once then we
check all the neighbors of s.
a gets added once, then we
check all the neighbors of a.
Each of these guys
gets added once.
We check all the neighbors.
So the total running
time is going
to be the sum over all
vertices of the size
of the adjacency list of v. So
this is the number of neighbors
that v has.
And this is going to be?
Answer?
AUDIENCE: Two times
the number of edges.
PROFESSOR: Sorry
AUDIENCE: Double
the number of edges.
PROFESSOR: Twice the number of
edges for undirected graphs.
It's going to be the number
of edges for directed graphs.
This is the Handshaking Lemma.
If you don't remember
the Handshaking Lemma,
you should read the textbook.
Six o four two stuff.
Basically you visit
every edge twice.
For directed graphs, you
visit every edge once.
But it's order E. We
also spend order V
because we touch every vertex.
So the total running
time is order V plus E.
In fact, the way this is going,
you can be a little tighter
and say it's order E. I just
want to mention in reality--
Sometimes you don't care about
just what you can reach from s,
you really want to
visit every vertex.
Then you need another
outer loop that's
iterating over all the vertices
as potential choices for s.
And you then can visit all the
vertices in the entire graph
even if it's disconnected.
We'll talk more about
that next class.
That's it for BFS.